Hello everyone, welcome to another stream.
We're working on the name, we're working on the name.
J-Rise and Rishi Cup have been sending some names.
We are here getting the game on and answering your questions with my fellow co-host, Rishi
Cup TV.
Rishi, welcome back.
Thanks Evan, glad to be here.
Happy Monday Believe Nation.
What is in the cup?
Cup of Gratitude, just had a great time on the Gratitude stream that you had just started
today.
That was a lot of fun.
Yeah, we talked about that on Friday.
We talked about doing that on Friday and boom, here we are on Monday.
Next day getting it done.
So I'm going to try that for the week.
See how that goes.
9am, 10 minutes of Gratitude with Believe Nation and see what's up.
Fabulous.
I'm ready to get into a game here, answer some questions.
Did we talk about what's in the cup?
Yes, Gratitude.
I've got my usual vitamin drink and smoothie and water.
So this is good.
I'm excited, I'm ready to go.
We got people in the Twitch chat too, just going to drop a welcome all here.
Yeah, shout out to Zano and more coming.
Oh, it doesn't recognize me as a leader here so I can't actually chat.
Alright, whatever, we'll figure that out later.
Alright, so let's do it.
First question, what do we got?
Who's up?
Alright, first question comes from Raquel.
Raquel is from Brazil and she admires your work a lot Evan.
Thank you Raquel.
She wants to know, yeah, she wants to know would you help mentor her in her, she wants
to build a business and she just would love to have you as a mentor.
We get this question a lot, don't we Evan?
Yep.
Lots of people want to be mentored by Evan, hashtag mentor me Evan.
It's a new stream.
Yeah, but what we've talked about a lot is that, you know, really the best way to get
mentored by Evan is watching, I mean there's just so much that you're pouring out value
every day on your channel and I know that your mission is to really, you kind of consider
mentoring something that you could just scale in the largest amount possible so you're
trying to reach, I know, one billion entrepreneurs which means that you're not necessarily always
making yourself available for one on one mentoring but hey, I am getting mentored by Evan every
single day as I watch videos and you're not limited by anything but your hunger if you
stay tuned to the Believe Channel and get active in Believe Nation and be a part of
live stream and yeah, so that's what I got, what do you think Evan, anything you want
to add to that?
You're not limited by anything but your hunger, look at that.
Hello Rishi on a Monday morning, vision some motivation, I like that.
So a couple thoughts, first off, I already am, right, like to Rishi's point, I already
am mentoring you, like the videos are there, I mentor myself with the videos, right, like
maybe not what I'm saying but the top ten rules, the Believe Life, all of that is for
me to get mentorship for myself and I don't want to downplay the importance of having
somebody face to face that you can ask help for but don't let that limit you, like if
you don't have somebody in your life that you can go up to and ask personal questions
to, oh we got a game going here, there's so much, I mean J-Rise was talking about how
he's grateful for YouTube, there's so many resources online that you can just get to,
oh I'm playing mid, that's going to be interesting, okay, should I do Heimer mid or Teemo mid,
what do you think Rishi, Rishi you pick.
Heimer, Heimer mid.
Back to Heimer?
Yeah, I like Heimer.
Oh wait, J-Rise wants the Heimer top, okay, I'll Teemo, okay, Teemo's good too, I'll have
to Teemo, let me ban, let me ban, sorry guys, I got to ban somebody here, oh, I'll Teemo
top, I don't know how to message J anymore, this is, this is confusion, I'll Teemo top,
I mean, I'll Teemo mid J, if you want time, there we go, I'll switch that up, this is
kind of awkward here, there we go, okay, yeah, and so like look at the people on my wall
here, right, you know, you can't see this one, I don't think in the live stream, but
this is Steve Jobs and Howard Schultz, my parents and Ipigenini, Kanye, you know, I've
never met, well, I've met my parents, but aside from my parents, you know, I haven't
met any of these people, two of them I can't meet because, you know, they passed on, two
of them I hope to meet someday, but you can learn a lot from people who are just putting
out content, who have interviews, who there's top ten rules on, and so go out and start
investing in yourself and make a list of people that you want to learn from.
Part of what I love about the top ten too and the content we're creating is I don't
know a lot of the people before we put them up, like there's a number of people who've
had tons of success and had great ideas that I never heard of before somebody asked me
to do, and then others who I totally didn't give a lot of respect to or didn't really
know a lot about, so like Selena Gomez has an amazing top ten video we did on her, and
Denzel Washington had a great top ten video out, and lots of other people too, and just
not just writing that person off, like what am I going to learn from Selena Gomez or what
am I going to learn from Denzel Washington, but they have a lot of great stuff out there
that I can learn from, so that is your easiest first step is that recognizing you are already
being mentored and take it more upon yourself to go out and continue in that tradition.
That's it.
I don't really do a lot of one-on-one mentoring.
I do have a package through my book that if you buy a certain number of copies you can
get some either one-off mentoring or six months of mentoring, which I don't normally do, and
it's only because the work that I want to do is at scale, where I love being able to
help people one-on-one as well, but it's hard to scale.
I want to help a billion entrepreneurs, and it doesn't happen by spending six months helping
one person, so the stuff that I do, I want it to be at just a bigger scale, so as much
as I love helping people one-on-one, and still do, like yesterday I met down with entrepreneurs,
stopping them at a coffee shop, I have to almost force myself not to, because I'm not
tapping into my true potential to be able to reach a lot more people and have a bigger
impact on the world.
Yeah.
That's it.
Makes sense.
Shout out to, did we have a shout out to Damasta in the chat?
No.
Damasta, welcome aboard man.
You're welcome, and Ryze had some good value, he's given in the comments, he mentioned the
Mastermind group as well as the book, I mean, aside from the channel, now your book is out,
so that's also another way to get even more mentoring, so.
Yeah.
So we're getting into game.
I don't remember the last time I played Teemo Mid, it's a long time, and I don't think Jay
and I have ever done Teemo Mid Heimer top before, so this is a good experiment, but
we're all about the experiments on this stream, we've had a number of successful ones, so
I'm excited to try it up again.
I feel confident you will win today.
Oh wow, wow, well that's, you had a bold message this morning about hunger, and now a bold
prediction, a blind prediction there about what's going to happen, so I'm excited, let's
see what happens.
Oh gosh, okay, next question comes from Praneeth, Praneeth says, I'm a software engineer, and
he works for Intel currently, he wants to start his own company developing an app, and
solving real problems, for example, maybe like an online store, or online platform where
you can deliver groceries, and anyway, he's just got some insecurities, and that is related
to finances, because, you know, he wants to venture out and follow his dream of this app,
but he's worried about, you know, making enough money to be able to survive if he just
goes all in on the business, so he's basically wondering, is it better to raise some money
from working, continuing to work at Intel, and slowly start his own company, or kind
of should he get his hands dirty, and just, you know, kind of, in his words, get his hands
dirty in the early stages, so, well, I think this is a really, really common kind of dilemma
for people, I'm thinking now about Jen, from You So Much, and how, you know, she was at
a job, and then shares on her channel about how she jumped, you know, she just decided
to take the leap and leave her job so she could be all in on her business, I think that
there's no one right answer, I just think the most important thing is to decide what
are you willing to do, and what are the conditions you're willing to live with, I mean, I think,
if I'm not mistaken, Robert Kiyosaki, at one point, was living in his car, you know,
I think I'm wrong about that, but I've heard stories about, I've heard stories about the
lengths that entrepreneurs will go to to make their dream a reality, i.e. living in your
car for a season, because they are willing to live at that level so that they can achieve
their goal, so I don't think there's one right answer, it's about what's right for
you, and what are you willing, like what lifestyle are you willing to live, and do you love that
app idea enough to suffer for it, you know, so I think Evan, one of your videos talked
about passion, the root of passion is to suffer, so are you willing to suffer for your
passion, and only you can determine what level of willingness of suffering, and hey, I'll
be the first one to say, I don't know, I'll be the first one to say, like, I want to know
that I can always buy my cup of coffee every day, and there's certain luxuries that I like,
and I don't know if I'd be willing to live in my car, I don't know, but that's a decision
that only you can make, so I don't think there's a right answer, but it's what's right for
you and what are you willing to live with, what do you think Evan?
Yeah, first thing I realize is that when I play a lane, like so I'm playing mid instead
of jungle, there's a lot more focus that has to go in, this is going to be a lot harder
than I expected, but it's okay, there's a lot of focus that has to go into actually
playing the match up, because I'm playing, I'm like actually fighting against somebody
instead of just taking out, playing against a computer kind of thing with the robots,
but that's okay, well, it's experiments, that's what this is all about, yeah, so I didn't
understand, does he have the skills to actually do the app programming, or is that not in
there?
He's a software engineer, so it sounds like he does.
Okay, so he can do it.
Yeah.
If it were me, you know, my typical advice is, the typical advice, typical EC advice
is I like starting stuff on the side, like this, what are we doing right now, right,
this is an experiment, what was my Monday morning stream on gratitude, it's an experiment,
I love starting small experiments on the side, I want to do small tests, see if it works,
see if I like it, see if we're getting results, see if it makes me come alive, see if I want
to continue to experiment and try new things out, or if I, you know, realize it's not for
me and I quit, because it's been a ton of stuff that I've also quit and gave up on because
it just didn't float my boat, it wasn't something I was super passionate about, but it's worth
an experiment to see and try.
So if you have the skills to do the programming, then I would be like, what are you doing when
you get home from Intel, that's what I would be focused on, you know, wake up a little
bit earlier and focus on coding, or when you get home from work, you know, focus on coding,
right, I'd be spending time every day to make sure I'm moving forward on my dream, extra
hard on the weekends, to get my hustle on and make sure that I'm seeing if it'll work.
I don't think the option is raise money while you still have your, like, who's going to
give you money so you can keep your full-time job, right, like, unless you're taking money
out of a bank, so you're taking out a loan, but no investor's going to want to give you
money so that you can keep your job and then try to go out and program, oh, I'm not doing
well here, this is rough, I should have done Hymer, you know what, I should have not traded
with Jay because Hymer is so much easier to play, I can go more autopilot, anyway, it's
good, good lesson, like, nobody's going to give you money to do it unless you're taking
money out of the bank, which is not something I would recommend, I hate going, I hate, I
hate spending money, you know, you guys know me, I hate spending money before making money,
so yeah, I'd be investing my hustle, investing my time on the side to make sure that I could
try to get something working.
The one caveat is some people have that personality where they have to go all in.
It's not me, I hate it, like, I love the experience, but think about, like, if you were a smoker
and you're trying to quit smoking, do you go just cold turkey and go all in and that's
your personality style, like, I'm either, I'm doing it or I'm not doing it, it's because
some people have that and it's, I think it can, I think it can hurt, because if you go
all in, you're going to be quickly running out of money, right, so you'll have, you know,
three months worth of money to live on and you have to make it in that three months,
but some people need that, some people need that pressure, they need to burn the boats
and not have a backup plan and just go all in and make it happen, so if that's you, that
would be my only caveat to leaving your job.
Oh, I got a gank, did not see, I did not see, I did not see.
My teammate came to help me, but I wasn't paying attention, so, well, we did okay there.
Yeah, so that would be my only caveat, like, if you have that kind of personality where
you have to go all in and you know you can't commit to doing something on the side and
you're just always going to slack off unless you force yourself to, you know, quit your
job and do it, then that's the advice, but it's a lot riskier play and I hate having
to do that personally.
That's what I got.
And good luck.
And what's the app about?
Great.
What was the app about?
Did he say what the app was about?
Yeah, he wants to solve basically real problems, for example, like an app that delivers groceries.
Yeah, but what does his app do?
That part is not included.
Right, okay, so like how long was that message?
How long was the message?
Yeah, how long was it, like he emailed in, right?
How long was that email in?
Oh, um, it was like, I can't remember because I would take a little snippet of it.
Got it.
Well, it was longer than a little snippet.
It was longer than a little snippet, right?
So instead of complaining about how most people don't do real stuff, right?
Tell me in that message what it's all about.
Like maybe I could have helped you with something, right?
Or maybe someone's listening to this stream or watching this channel and they say, oh,
that's a great idea.
I want to be a part of it, right?
Without giving away everything, you know, by sharing a little bit allows you to build
a team and get people on your side.
So you know, and that's a lesson for everybody.
If you want people to help you, you have to give a little bit more context and definitely
not just kind of complaining about the status quo.
Give me your solution.
Great.
Okay, um, we have a question actually in the chat today.
All right.
I like it.
Yeah, from Damasta.
He's actually got a question specifically about your channel and TDS.
He says, in what ways, uh, and actually Damasta, I should not assume that you are a guy.
I don't know if you're a guy or girl, so in what ways do you actively practice social
sustainability with your channel or with TDS?
Social sustainability with my channel or TDS.
I wonder what he means by social sustainability.
Yeah, I was going to ask that question as well.
If you can clarify Damasta, what specifically would you want to know?
Since he's watching live, let's, let's get some, let's get some added clarity on that.
Leave it in the chat.
Okay.
Rishi's paying attention.
I am not.
I am paying attention to Rishi and trying not to die.
Uh, but yeah, let's get some added clarity.
What does that mean?
Because I would love to answer the live question too.
Great.
All right.
And you're doing great.
I can see you.
It looks like even though you're, uh, you've got more on your hands today, it looks like
you're doing great.
Yeah, I'm actually, I'm ahead of this guy surprisingly somehow, but I'm excited.
This is the, Rishi called the wind, so I better deliver for her.
Oh man.
All right.
Next question comes from Fazal and Fazal says I'm in an environment which I don't like and
it's not serving me.
Um, I want to move to another country, but I also have a chance to study here in my country
for free, so I don't know what's better.
Should I, you know, move or take advantage of my free studies here where, where he is.
Right.
So, yeah, I mean this is another one of those things that I think we were talking about
with, with, uh, some of these life questions are things that I think you've got to kind
of dig deep and ask yourself what's in your gut and in your heart for what is right for
you.
Um, I don't know if the studies that you have available to you for free, uh, if they are
something that can further you in the direction that you want to go.
I'm assuming you're an entrepreneur.
So hey, if, if someone's giving you a free education and you can take advantage of it
so that it can further you along in what it is that you want to do and, and it can help
you build a network and it can help you get mentoring or whatever, you know, identifying
one of the things that you need for where you want to go and maybe that education can
provide that.
Maybe it can't, but I think most importantly, you know what you want and you know what you
want to do.
And so that will help you decide what's the best way to get there.
Um, environment, Evan, you talk a lot about environment.
Um, so when you say your environment's not serving you, I'd be curious what that means
to you.
I mean, um, lots of people think, well, I live in this country, so you know, that's
going to hinder me from achieving my goals.
Whereas most of the time that's actually just an excuse that we will tell ourselves.
Um, so I think it's, I think it's a complex question that obviously doesn't have a one
right answer, but I think that the most connected you are to who you are, what you want and
where you want to go will at least get you closer to knowing, uh, how to answer that
question for yourself.
Um, and hey, plenty of people move all the time because they're interested in a particular
industry and, and they want to be where that industry is.
So there's nothing wrong with moving either, but I think it's just really knowing what,
what do you want and you know, what are the goals that you're trying to achieve?
I like it.
While that was happening, I got, I got a kill, so I'm pretty excited.
I'm going to be honest, I'm pretty excited about that one.
I was expecting to really not do well in lane, but, uh, things, things are going well.
Um, I got a little distracted there.
Uh, so yeah, in terms of, so education really with all big decisions, um, it's hard overhead.
It doesn't always make the most sense, uh, to do the things that you know, you need to
do that's best for you.
I'm sure it's easy.
Like it's the easy path, which still may be the one to take, like maybe you should be
taking the easy path, but, um, it doesn't mean that it's necessarily the right path.
And one of the things that really helped me when I was in university, it wasn't about
where to go to university.
I didn't, I liked where I went, but more, um, what I wanted to do coming out of university,
it was the, the, the stupid thing, like the, the not smart thing, the thing that didn't
make a lot of sense logically to turn down, you know, high paying jobs to do my own business
where I'm making like no money.
What helped me through was figuring out that I didn't want to live with regret.
And so I would be looking at your situation now and saying, if you have this potential
opportunity to go somewhere else and you know, your environment isn't great and you want
to go and learn and you don't take it now, will you regret that?
Or if not, then great, don't worry about it, right?
Like if you think, Hey, you know what, I'll try the free one.
If it doesn't work, I can go next year, you know, like give it a shot on the free one.
And if I'm not liking it, I'll transfer out next year.
Great.
Like, yeah, that's true.
That can work too.
Just what are you going to regret least?
Like is anything going to lead to you having massive regret in this situation?
And if it is, and I'd be looking at, um, how to avoid it.
And often the thing that you might regret is a thing that you are afraid of.
Uh, and so there might be, you know, it's, it's usually not the ones, the safe path.
It's the, it's a crazy idea.
It's the one that, you know, everybody tells you that you shouldn't be doing.
Um, so that's it.
It's like for all of these decisions, major life decisions, you know, what business to
support, who to marry, what school to go to, you know, what job to take, uh, what city
I should live in, you know, all of those ones where you might think, Hey, I'm going to,
I'm going to make that list of pros and cons and logically work my way through this.
At the end of the day, it's not a logical thing that will save you.
Um, it has to be through something that your heart is, is in on.
So big decisions with the heart, small ones with the head, always every situation.
And when you make that big decision with your heart, your head will help you figure it out.
Right?
It's like, okay, my heart really says, go do this education somewhere else.
Okay, great.
Now your head can help you figure out how to go and do it.
So that's my advice and good luck.
Yeah.
Good stuff.
All right.
Um, next question comes from Napro and Napro is asking, Hey Evan, I'm not sure if you have
a video about this, but I'd like to know your top 10 cities for fitness tech entrepreneurs.
Wow.
Okay.
I love it.
I love the, uh, I love the randomness.
This is great.
Yeah.
So, um, you know, I, I personally can't say I have a top 10 for this, but I would say,
um, if you're interested in fitness tech, I know, uh, some of the leading companies
right now are companies like Fitbit, which Evan, I don't think you're doing your Fitbit
this morning.
I do.
No, no, I, I'm just not walking.
It's, I can't constantly, I have like 4,000 steps there.
It's not, it's not a lot, but, but I cannot add this to answering questions.
It's my limitation at the moment.
Maybe I'll work on it.
One of these days I'll get there.
Yes.
Okay.
So Evan, Evan loves his Fitbit.
Um, I know Nike, I mean Nike, we all know Nike, fit wall, uh, jawbone.
So I would look into these leaders of fitness tech and, you know, find out where they are
and uh, maybe that'll help you.
I don't know if you know, pro are interested in, um, moving somewhere where there are,
uh, these industry leaders, but, uh, yeah, I just, I would just take some time to research
where those companies are and, uh, make your own, make your, how about you make your own
list of tops and cities and then email us what you get back as your, your research.
All right.
This one is a hard one for me.
I have two conflicting, uh, I have two conflicting thoughts.
One, so the, the, the easy one is like, I don't know, you know, I don't, I don't keep
track of that stuff.
I don't, I don't have a city that I would recommend you go see.
So I can't add a specific, I can't directly answer your question.
Um, but in terms of kind of adding more value to the topic on one hand, I am a big believer
that the environment matters and that you need to, you know, be somewhere where you're
surrounded by people who make you come alive.
On the other hand, I love my city so much that I can't imagine another city that I would
ever want to go to.
And, and my approach is I want to make Toronto great and I get, I get upset when people want
to leave to go to where they feel like they have to go to New York or, or Boston or, or
California or wherever to start a business.
Uh, I, I want to make this city amazing.
And so, I don't know, those, those, those two ideas are, they seem opposite, right?
Cause if environment is really important, then you should be where, where the good stuff
is happening.
Um, but my, my, maybe it's my, my local pride or just my, my own confidence in that I feel
like just, just make it, make it amazing yourself.
Like there, there's, there's amazing things around you.
And like my belief is wherever I am has to, that city has to be amazing.
Yes.
Um, I don't know if we helped, I don't know if we helped answer that question, but, uh,
that was a tough one.
Well, I think you're, as usual, you are instinctively going kind of, I think to what is the heart
of it, which is, you know, this, I think we can fall into this thing where we're, we are
chasing, um, something that we already, you know, it, it's what often limits us is we're
waiting to have this perfect circumstance to be able to, you know, get what it is that
we want when really we are able to do it right now where we are with what's in your cup.
Hello.
There you go.
Wow.
Rishi is turning up today.
I like this Monday morning.
Rishi.
Oh, so I don't know.
I just think that, um, it is important to know where the industries are, but like you
were saying it, you know, it really, I think you're just tapping into what might be the,
you're giving value to what is really, I think at the heart of the question.
Um, but rise online also says, uh, Silicon Valley and the chat, that's obviously a huge
industry, uh, for tech.
And so Silicon Valley for sure is a great, um, location to add to that top 10.
So yeah, I think I'm just too counter culture, you know, like I, uh, I, I don't, I would
never move to a city just for business.
Uh, I, I mean, unfortunately I live in a great city to start with.
So maybe if I lived in, you know, some tiny farmland or something where, you know, maybe,
maybe my mind would change.
Um, but the people that I respect, if I look at, at cities, I don't, I don't really like
have a ton of respect for the Silicon Valley and it's not that I disrespect them, but what,
what people like Tony Shay are doing with, they're trying to build Las Vegas into something
like trying to recruit people to come to their city and make it amazing.
That, that is something that I have just a ton more respect for and something that I
would want to do, like I want to figure out how to bring that to my city, to bring that
to Toronto.
Um, so I don't know, I might be the, uh, I'm a weird person to ask this question to.
I appreciate it though.
I appreciate the question.
All right.
Um, going back to Damasta, oh, we got follow up, follow up on the line.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah.
Yep.
Damasta, when he was talking about social sustainability, what he means is, um, kind
of what are your decisions about, um, lending to being green, environmentally friendly or
lending to charity, helping, um, some world cause.
It sounds like he just kind of is curious to know, um, you know, maybe your, uh, philanthropic
goals or the things that you are wanting to achieve, um, on a more social level.
Got it.
Okay.
So this might be just a philosophical difference because I believe that, that you don't have
to be a charity to, I think entrepreneurs solve the global problems of the world.
Like what I do is social, is giving back, is making the world better.
I don't do a lot of it through the, through the lens of donating to charities, uh, or
just following, you know, green best practices.
Um, not that those aren't great things to do as well, but if you look at what I'm great
at, uh, and the impact that I want to have, it's through entrepreneurship, oh I just
got a crazy light spike, what happened there, okay I'm back, um, so, you know, the biggest
initiative that I've probably done is I do, I, I, I do a project with Kiva where we've
helped raise, let me go back, where we raised over a hundred thousand dollars for entrepreneurs
in Africa, um, and like parts of the sales that we made, I need to do seminars, um, and
you know, the money raised would go to support those entrepreneurs and to build in something
better for themselves.
But like I never made a huge deal about that, it's not all over my website, um, and I am
proud of it.
It was, it was more someone on my team's initiative, I said, hey, what do you, what, like she loved
this cause, I said, oh, I can, I can contribute to that by doing what I know and helping entrepreneurs.
But the reason why I want to help a billion entrepreneurs is because the planet will be
so much better because we're going to solve all the major problems, like that, that last
guy that, I forget his name, but, um, said that he wants to do something meaningful,
something big, something not just, uh, the same app that everybody else is doing, right?
Um, yes, got the kill.
Rishi man, I have four kills, no deaths, two assists, this is, this is happening.
This is happening.
I see it.
This is, this is real game here.
Um, yeah, so I think that the work that I'm doing is the greatest social cause of all.
And I think, I think you should be doing whatever, like whatever best helps the planet in your
eyes, you should go out and do that.
Like, you know, you don't have to live through my world and see the world that I, that I
see, you should be out doing your own big thing and having the impact that you want
to go out and have.
And maybe for you that is doing, you know, helping people eat more green, you know, and
having less organic or having less pollutants in the environment or whatever it is.
There's a question that somebody always asks in a live stream that I watch, uh, and it's,
it's along the lines of if you had all the money in the world, uh, what would you, what,
what, what would you spend it on?
Like what, what disease would you solve or what would you spend that money on?
And inevitably most people say something that that has, that has big like world value,
like, uh, you know, I want to solve cancer, whatever.
My take on it is if there's some big thing that you want to do, don't wait.
Like you should be doing it in a small way already.
Isn't that the truth?
Why are you waiting until you have a million dollars or whatever?
You have an ability right now to go out and do it.
So do it in a small way, right?
Like if I had a billion dollars, I would be helping entrepreneurs and that's what I'm
doing right now.
Just in a smaller way.
Right?
So I don't know.
It boggles my mind.
Like if there's something that you really want to do, there's some big impact you want
to have on the world, then then start now.
Just go out and do it just in a smaller way.
There's nothing stopping you.
Yeah.
Anyway, that's my rant.
I'm glad I got a chance to bring up that rant.
Yeah, that's really a good rant and you will do what you're passionate about at any scale.
And it's funny, like people think too, you know, if I get all this money, I would help
this or that cause.
But actually, you find that when people get a lot of money, they end up actually just
doing what they were doing before they got all that money.
Sure.
You know, we can deceive ourselves into thinking that if we have more money, we're going to
somehow do something different, you know.
All right.
Continuing to dominate in the game here as we move on to the next question.
Let's do it.
So Andrew asks, I want to pick your brain about narrowing your focus.
I'm 26 years old.
I got my BA last year and he was flip flopping a lot on his major.
Now he's working in an unrelated job with the intent in the world to get out and move
forward.
But I have too many visions and interests.
And so he just wants to get some feedback.
You know, what do you do when you don't really have a narrow focus?
How do you start?
Got it.
This is a question that I relate to a lot because, you know, I am one of those people
who just didn't have that one thing that was clear from the start.
And, you know, it's been a challenge for me because I have a lot of passions for a lot
of different things.
So for a lot of years, I would do one thing and I would excel in that one thing, but it
would ultimately not be really fulfilling for me because it felt like I was choosing
this one thing at the expense of another thing.
And so like, you know, for years I was the dancer and then I was the, you know, and then
I focused on the singing and I was the singer.
And then there were years I was the teacher and, you know, it brought success, but I never
felt fulfilled because I decided to narrow this focus and it was at the expense of other
passions and interests.
So I think that some people are like this.
They have a lot of different interests and a lot of different passions.
And I get that there's always going to be this pressure to pick one and just be this
one thing.
But the whole reason I started my YouTube channel was to honor and acknowledge the whole
me.
And so for me, that means I'm a dancer, I'm a singer, I am someone who loves to do talk
show type segments.
I like to do educational videos.
I mean, there's just all of the things that I've been up until this point are being able
to be brought into my YouTube space.
And I do still get a pressure to focus and, you know, I'll get the question like, but
what exactly are you doing?
And it's kind of like letting me know that, you know, this isn't the right way to go.
And as I continue to do it, I'm hoping that I'll continue to improve.
But I think that the more you can honor who you are, and find something that that can
bring all your strengths together in a way that you know, is unique to you, I think you're
going to find the most not just the most successful, the most fulfillment.
Because for me, success is not just being able to make the money, it's feeling personally
fulfilled and like you are doing meaningful work.
So I think it's easy to say, how do I just narrow my focus and do this one thing.
But for me, it's all about pursuing the and all of the interests and the passions and
letting them lead you wherever they take you.
And hopefully, you know that that will help you get closer and closer each day.
I like it we're we're on our way to victory.
Wow, we're getting close.
We're getting close.
It's pretty close.
It's not it's not a not guaranteed yet, but it's pretty close.
I just I went blank.
What was the question again?
Just quick.
I know.
And I just want to narrow your focus when you have a lot of it's like, where should
you start?
Yes.
And we just won.
All right.
GG.
Sorry.
It was crazy.
It's like we're all on the base.
It's like this insanity happening.
But that was good.
Let's give a quick recap of how we're doing and what the final score was here.
It's just loading up.
And then I'm going to answer that question because I'm excited.
I got an S. Good game will play off.
I went seven kills, no deaths, four assists and we won.
Feeling pretty excited about it.
Good.
I think she called it another victory.
The undefeated streak on the stream seems to be going well.
I think in the 2016 world, you should have a hard time explaining what you do.
I used to hate that.
I couldn't explain what I did.
And I would just say I'm an entrepreneur or I help entrepreneurs or and the people say,
well, like a like a coach, like a consultant, really kind of like.
I think it's good, though, I think it's good not to just sit in a box.
I think the people who have an easy job explaining what they do are in a box and aren't doing
anything great.
I think the people who who have more I mean, I think we all have the depth.
I think we all have the ability to have the depth.
And I think we all have the ability to take different things.
If you want your true genius to come out, it's got to be by combining different things
together that only you can do.
I call it the genius of the end is from what's the book, Jim Collins, I forget the book anyway.
It's a genius at the end.
Find the things that only you can do together.
Right.
Like, look at what I'm doing here as an example is a test, right?
We have League of Legends, we have entrepreneurship.
Nobody's doing this right now doesn't mean it's going to be super successful.
We're trying we're seeing we're building up.
You know, we've got more viewers than we had last time, hopefully it's having an impact.
But your magic will come when you do the two or three or four things together.
The key thing is you find a way to integrate them.
So you're not doing this on one side and this and the other thing is you're going to feel
like you're all over the place.
And people will tell you, you got to be focused.
It's finding a way to integrate all of your talents together into one business that represents
all the things that you have a passion for.
If you do that, that's where you're going to like you need to do that.
Otherwise just go get a job and sit in the box and you can say you are a lawyer or you
are an accountant.
Right.
And it makes it easy over dinners to explain what your job is, but it's not going to be
fulfilling.
And you know, I think there's no excuse in the world that we're living now.
It's just so easy to get started.
There's so many resources available that if you can figure out what that combination
is and explore until you figure it out.
You know, the gratitude stream this morning was an example, like who's doing gratitude
for entrepreneurs?
You know, lots of people do gratitude, but specifically entrepreneurs, nobody's doing
it.
And I'm interested in both.
So I'm going to try it.
It felt pretty good this morning.
You know, I liked it.
We had a nice 10 minute stream.
Will that continue?
I don't know.
And then see how it goes if I keep wanting to do it.
See people keep wanting to show up.
The league stream, you know, we're upping the number of days that we do it.
Will it continue to work?
I don't know.
But we're testing.
We're trying.
We're seeing and being okay with kind of exploring your curiosity until you find the thing that
just really makes you come alive that's a man that's that's how I'm going to that's
how I'm going to execute it.
And so there was a video I think it was Anna I think it was the Anna Wintour and Spresso
that helped clarify this for me as well in that I feel like it's good to be able to
not describe in like I feel good that it's hard to explain what you do that it takes
a sentence to explain what you do this from the guy who wrote a book called Your One Word
you know like there's the there's the there's the caveat right there's the you know the
dichotomy but yeah I think you need to I think you need to go out and be able to make it
difficult to explain what you do get some depth to what you do in day in day out and
most importantly all those areas that you have how can you combine them into a focus
without having to give something up because if you give something up you're always going
to feel like I wish I still did that and did I make the right choice and you're always
going to do it and there's always going to be a piece of you that's missing because you
want to go out and do that so figure out a way to do all of them together where doing
one helps the other and helps the other instead of doing four different things that are on
their own island right build your build your own country where all four things exist on
that same country instead of having to hop between four different islands so you know
this dream most of the people watching I'm assuming came from my youtube channel but
if we get somebody new from twitch watching that helps my youtube channel you know when
I go out and speak or when I write my book I don't have a copy here you know that brings
out a new audience that helps my youtube channel helps my website it helps my speaking right
everything I'm doing a ton of different things but they're all connected to each other when
I do one it helps the other one succeed as well instead of the opposite where if you
focus if you live on four different islands when you do one you're hurting the others
because you're not spending your time there so you're actually taking away from the others
where if you're if you combine all of them when you spend time on one you're helping
the others build momentum as well and figure that out that's the real focus that will help
you succeed I'm excited that's a great question and so another victory guys I need to show
you here right like I win 261 and I've lost 252 so I lose a lot just not on stream so
it was another fun session Rishi final thoughts final words you started with with hunger you
dropped some motivational advice what do we what are we closing the session on well I think on your
last point you know just encouraging everybody to discover what's in your cup and to pursue the
business that acknowledges all of who you are and I loved how you said you know if if you don't
there's always a piece that's missing and so that's what I'm trying to do every she kept
TV is encourage people to bring all the pieces together and integrate it into whatever it is
that you want to do and how you want to impact the world so great great way to end cool well
thank you guys for watching thank you Rishi for for the energy and advice thank you Jay for the
great game another victory and we'll see you again tomorrow morning continue to believe whatever
your one word is we'll see you then